The Art of performing magic is really
the art of managing attention up here.
Look at the car at three to three,
three,
three.
It doesn't matter.
The general rule of thumb is that when a
magician says that something doesn't
matter,
the opposite is usually true.
For example,
a couple of minutes ago when David
Blaine flipped three more cards into
what everyone else thinks is a pile of
10,
then asked to read to put them over his
heart.
The only thing that matters is that
Jimmy Fallon chooses the number three
from this forced flourish so that when
Blaine says that three cards will
magically fly from his deck into creeks
hand,
the 13 cards will be there and everyone
will freak out.
10 zero.
Did you catch it that time?
Ten,
10,
zero.
There's three and there's four more.
Now there's 20 cards.
This is a great trick from David Blaine
and it functions on a simple concept
which all magic depends on selective
attention.
The idea that the eyes and the mind can
only focus on one thing at a time.
This principle is something that
magicians have known for centuries in
the earliest known book of Magic and
English Hocus pocus.
The author includes in his four required
skills for magic tricks such gestures of
body as may lead the spectators eyes
from a strict and diligent beholding of
his manner of conveyance.
A few hundred years later,
scientists began conducting tests on
selective attention like this one from
deckland serve owned from 1983,
which asked subjects to count the number
of times the white shirted players pass
the ball back and forth and this in
other tests like it.
A majority of people,
more than half fail to see the woman
with the umbrella walking directly
through the middle of the scene.
The important thing to note is that
selected the tension is something that
organizes our entire experience as human
beings,
not just our vision.
I mean,
David Blaine may be distracting Jimmy
Fallon and the roots when he loads these
extra cards into the pile,
but what's more amazing than the slight
of hand is that he's doing it in exactly
the place where everyone is looking and
this shows just how powerful selective
attention can be in magic.
Manipulating attention is fun.
It's what we expect,
but it's not the only place we find this
kind of activity.
Let's take a look at another trick.
Are you watching closely on Sunday,
November 27th,
The New York Times published a
comprehensive piece of good journalism
detailing country by country,
the empire of business interests that
Donald trump has around the globe and
how they might conflict with his job as
president.
The story was at the top of the front
page.
Then at around 1230 that afternoon,
trump tweeted this,
in addition to winning the electoral
college in a landslide,
I won the popular vote.
If you deduct the millions of people who
voted illegally,
make no mistake.
This is a kind of magic trick like David
Blaine,
like any magician,
Donald Trump is using selective
attention for his own gain.
He's misdirecting sucking all the air
out of a story that he wants you to
forget.
Mr [inaudible] is not new to politics.
Politicians have been manipulating our
attention for years.
I mean when the public asks a question
politicians figured out long ago that
rather than actually answer it,
it's much,
much better to change the question.
When you address negative publicity on
its own terms,
you end up with stuff like this.
People have got to know whether or not
their president is a crook.
Well,
I'm not a crook.
I earned everything I've got.
Instead of moving attention away from
the question of his criminality,
Nixon aim the focus directly onto that
issue by denying it outright.
A better magic trick is something that
happened a few years earlier when
Vietnam war protests were gripping the
country in the 19 sixties,
politicians and elites who supported the
war didn't address the protestors actual
concerns about the legitimacy of the
conflict.
Instead,
they reframed the antiwar protests as
anti troop protests,
and this political sleight of hand has
proven really fruitful and undercutting
protesters,
not just the Vietnam War,
the Gulf War,
and the war on terror.
Scare every American to find a way to
thank the men and women who are
defending our freedom.
I'm Donald Trump.
Takes this a step further.
He uses twitter to maneuver attention
away from negative press,
but he doesn't reframe the debate so
much as distract the country with
statements so glaringly false and
controversial,
but the media is forced to expend its
energy on refuting them or covering them
because they have to because the winning
president elect saying without evidence
that millions of people voted illegally
will get ratings because when the
president makes a force of the
presidency,
that is in some sad way newsworthy,
and then when you're done covering that,
a new tweet comes in that says flag
burners should perhaps lose their
citizenship or be sent to jail for a
year.
I mean,
it's really amazing.
The attention goes where he wants it to
go and without the pressure of sustained
focus.
The Chairman of the House oversight
committee is free to brush the real
issue.
The one we all forgot about aside,
I think you can expect this kind of
thing for the next four years.
Expect every substantive criticism to be
met with a ridiculous tweet.
It's time for all of us to start
thinking of our own attention as a
limited and valuable resource because
when you do,
you can be a little more certain that
the card,
your choosing.
It's actually yours.
Stop.
There is a new nerd writer video every
Wednesday guys.
So if you click that box that I've
conveniently set up right there,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos up.
Sorry,
David Blaine for revealing how your
trick is done.
Um,
but it was a useful metaphor for what I
wanted to talk about.
Thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
They make a sleek,
intuitive websites where you can go and
make a website without having to know
coding.
I made one called the nerd writer.net,
which you can check out and see sort of
an example.
If you sign up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and if
you use the offer code nerdwriter you
get 10 percent off your first purchase.
Thank you for helping to fund this
channel without asking to interfere in
the content.
That's a huge thing for me as as a lot
of you guys know.
Anyway else.
See the rest of you next Wednesday.